Gooey melted marshmallows dripping with chocolate,
and sandwiched between two graham crackers.
They taste so good, it makes you want s'more.
But if you've ever tried roasting marshmallows
on an open fire, they may have ended up a
bit more crispy than you ever intended. In
this project let's avoid the charred carbon
coating, by turning your empty drink cans,
into a simple and effective, s'mores roaster.
We’re all familiar with the term “lifehacks”, but this summer,
the guys at mike’s hard
lemonade asked me to help put a refreshing
twist on it with what they’re calling “mikehacks"
/ˈmīkˌhak/
noun: mikehack; plural noun: mikehacks; noun:
mike hack; plural noun: mike hacks
1. basically a lifehack that makes any social
occasion, more awesome.
This little contraption will help melt your
marshmallows and chocolate, to s'mores perfection,
making for a delicious ending to your summer socials. To start this project, we're gonna
need a 16 oz aluminum drink can, as well
as a pair of scissors, and a marker. Now,
if we turn the can upside down on a flat surface,
holding the marker a quarter of the way up
from the bottom, we can easily mark a line
around the can just by giving it one complete
turn. Let's go ahead and cut the top off the
can, making sure we stay about an inch above
the line, because this initial cut is gonna
come out pretty jagged. Now we can go ahead
and cut along the line, making sure we're
cutting counter clock-wise, so we end up with
a nice clean edge all around the top. Alright,
next we need to find something the same shape
and size as a box of toothpicks or matches.
And the size is important. You can see it's
gonna take a bit of manipulation, but the
end of the box should just barely fit inside
the can. Now if we set the can upright, and
push the box all the way to the bottom, we'll
be able to use it as a form to crease the
edges, and mold the can to the shape of the
box. At this point, let's gently pull the
box back out of the can, and you can see our
little roaster oven is halfway done. Now this container shape is perfect for accommodating
a couple of graham crackers, but the problem
is that everything keeps falling over forward.
Let's solve that challenge By adding some
feet. We'll need to snip each of the 4 corners,
about half an inch deep, then crease the sides
over flat against the can. If we bend them
back and forth a few times you can see they
make a clean break, and I like to trim the
corners off the can just to clean them up
a bit. If you did the same, the tabs on your
can should look something like this. Now,
if you look closely, you can see where I poked
two holes in the upper tab as well, and when
this is folded inside the can, and the bottom
feet are bent down like this, our s'mores
roaster is completely finished. All we need
to do now is load our crackers with some chocolate
and marshmallows, then tuck them inside the
can so we can get them roasting. Now if we
set this near the edge of a campfire with
the open end facing the flames, it should
only take a few minutes to get our marshmallows
toasting, to golden brown perfection. A quick
peek inside, and you can see everything is
soft and gooey, and looking delicious. Now
there are all kinds of other ways this can
be used as well. For a more adventurous approach,
I tried bending a coat hanger to form a make-shift
roasting stick, and slipped the forked end
inside the tab holes we made earlier. The
cool thing about this method is you can get
closer to the heat, and the flames don't actually
touch the marshmallows. So they shouldn't
catch on fire. Instead, everything gets melted
into a soft and gooey goodness that's completely
irresistible. Another idea you can try is
fitting the roaster between the gaps on your
cooking grill. The leftover heat from bbq'ing
should be just enough to make one of these
sweet and tasty treats. Well now you know
how to turn your empty aluminum drink cans,
into a flame resistant s'mores roaster, so
you'll never have to worry about carbon encrusted
marshmallows again. By the way, if you're
at home and don't feel like getting a fire
going, try setting a hairdryer to medium or
high heat, then aiming it inside the can.
In 2 minutes or less, you'll have the great
same results, without even having to strike
a match. Well that's it for now. If you liked
this project, perhaps you'll like some of
my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com